[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar I got a highly requested attack
on Titan video coming up for you guys on
Wednesday but in the meantime enjoy this
video where I'll tell you everything you
need to know about the deadly and also
mysterious stain for everyone that
requested the hero killer explained on
my every quirk video this one goes out
to you if you have any suggestions for
what might hear accademia video I should
do next let me know in the comments
below if you're new be sure to subscribe
for more videos like this one a quick
warning as per your requests there will
be among the spoilers we are going to
get to the truth behind the Enigma that
is stain and we'll need the help of
Japanese comics to do it proceed with
extreme caution
now if you're psyched and ready to go
Detroit smash that like button and let's
do this let's start with some basic
information stains real name is cheese
Omaha kaguro he is known as the villain
who has killed many Pro heroes he is 31
years old and looks like his design was
inspired by the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle his quirk is called blood curdle
after ingesting a person's blood stain
can paralyze his opponent how long the
person in question actually remains
paralyzed that immobile depends on the
person's blood types
people with B blood type are affected
for the longest period of time probably
because stains on blood type is B
following be the least resistant what
types are a B and then a people with old
blood types are the most resistant to
the quirk and recover the quickest from
paralysis however it is important to
note that's no matter what blood type
you are the maximum amount of time
anyone can be paralysed for is eight
minutes stains insane speed endurance
make it possible for him to get a hold
of his opponents blood in the first
place so that he can use his quirk he
also carries a crazy amount of weapons
that can draw blood from his opponents
including a katana five daggers throwing
knives toast bike boots and folding
knives according to the data book stain
statistics are as follows he scored a
three out of five in power but he makes
up for it with an off-the-charts score
of six out of five and
speed for technique he scored a five out
of five for intelligence he scored a
three out of five and for
cooperativeness he scored a one out of
five which definitely makes sense you
can tell he's no fun at a party now that
we've discussed some of Spain's powers
and abilities let's move on to his
mysterious past like that goo stain was
greatly inspired by all Mike he wanted
to become a hero just like all night so
he enrolled in a private hero course in
high school in order to pursue that
dream up to this point his story is very
similar to Dec ruse which i think is
significant it shows how easily one can
be led astray even when their motives
are good and pure same became
disillusioned in the high school when he
saw that students were becoming heroes
for the money and personal gain he could
not stand the fundamental decay as he
called it and dropped out during his
freshman year after he dropped out stain
preached his new ideology which he
called the revival of heroics he made
speeches on the streets but no one ever
listened to him and over the course of
the following decade he realized that
people only understand action he decided
that he could only create his ideal
world and save heroics through violence
only then would people start to pay
attention to him and his ideology is it
just me or is this guy kind of reminds
you of Keita except I don't believe that
stain would ever kill a selfless father
like light this light is much more
Machiavellian the ends always justify
the means well that does not seem to be
the case for stained stained actually
goes out of his way to avoid killing
people who he deems to be truly selfless
and heroic in fact as we will see
shortly stain even goes out of his way
to save people who he deems to be heroic
even if they are his opponents and they
keep getting in his way anyways after
his speeches failed to make a difference
staying trained himself in the killing
arts and during this time his parents
passed away it is not clear what exactly
happened to them but it is believed that
staying had nothing to do with him after
his training was complete stain began to
put his revival of heroics plan into
motion by murdering pro heroes he would
not stop his purge until the world
realized the flaw in the current corrupt
heroic system Thane's ultimate end goal
is to eradicate phonies or fakes who
practice heroics for selfish reasons
meaning those who are in it for the same
and money his hope is to create a just
world filled with true selfless heroes
who do not expect rewards for their
altruistic deed
fame is first introduced to us as an
evil villain albeit a cool one not only
does he seriously injured 10 sayyeda a
great and respected pro hero he is shown
grinning afterwards while licking blood
off of his night it seems as black and
white as it has been up to this point
this person is evil just like the League
of villain
however ironically stains character
actually serves to call into question
this naive you we had plenty Chloe's
world our first clue that stain is not
like the rest of the villains is the
fact that he completely rejects tota she
Gaddafi's philosophy stain says that
there is no sense in bloodshed without a
cause and that in order to accomplish
anything he needs a Creed aka a set of
beliefs or aims that guide someone's
action as stain says the only thing that
two have in common is that they want to
destroy the current society they are all
dead words by kudo giddy to hosu a
prosperous area that stain plans to
reform by sacrificing its sake heroes
stain explains that the title of hero
should only be granted to those who
achieve great undertakings and expect
nothing in return not to those who only
work for money stain finds a hero native
and immobilize them but then EDA appears
to avenge his older brother stain sees
that he is a child and tells him to
leave but EDA is set on revenge stain
uses his skills and work to defeat EDA
and called him and his brother who he
let lives to feed the rumors fake heroes
staying calls him out for acting
selfishly and prioritizing his own
revenge instead of the rescue of natives
showing that he is the furthest thing
from a true hero as stain is preparing
to kill EDA deck who comes in with a 5%
Detroit smash and punch sustains head
stain is surprisingly unfazed and even
more surprisingly he is impressed with
the consensus a visa and tells him that
there is value in keeping him a lot
stain has made the judgment as Deku is
like all light a true hero so for the
rest of their fight he holds back and
purposely avoids killing him he also
does the same with Todoroki who he also
judged worthy of the title of hero
eventually through teamwork the three
class one
students defeat Spain but barely and
declan Todoroki later agree that he was
holding back with them they tie him up
with a rope to prevent his escape but a
bit later so everyone surprised a flying
gnome who sweeps down from the sky grabs
Deku and begins flying away with him
then staying regains consciousness and
using the health of his quark
he defeats the wing normal and stabs him
in the brain risking his own safety in
this way he rescues Deku stain says at
this point that his targets are the fake
heroes and pathetic criminals of this
society and reiterates his point and
everything he is doing is for a just
world stains bandage mask falls off and
everyone is shocked to see that stains
nose has been carved out despite being
extremely injured Stane steps forward
toward a group of heroes and says that
the fake heroes must be rectified and
the word hero be restored he says that
someone has sustained themselves in
blood which explains his choice of name
even endeavors the second greatest hero
is visibly freaked out and steps back
from him as he approaches another pro
hero falls down in fear saying there's
the fakes to try and stop him and again
showing his respect for all night says
that all my is the only one that is
allowed to kill him as everyone is
stricken with fear strain finally passes
out due to his injury stain is arrested
and new spreads throughout Japan his
backstory inspires and causes a rise in
villainy since many agree with same
sentiments and dislike what Heroes has
become mistakenly believing that Spain
was a member of the League of villains
people who were inspired by his ideology
decides to unite themselves with the
league even though that is the last
thing Spain would have wanted this
really illustrates how easily a person
or an idea can be misinterpreted and
made to fit a narrative that is
completely opposed to reality ironically
Stane wanted to show people the truth
but accidentally contributed to
distorting it he wanted a just world but
his backstory contributed to the rise of
villainy and injustice after being
treated for his injuries
Spain is incarcerated in a special
prison where criminals apparently go
when the death penalty isn't even enough
of a punishment so there you have it
guys stain and his quirk explained let
me know what you think about staying in
the comment section below
who said before that he understands
saying to an extent at least but cannot
accept his behavior can you guys
emphasize with stain or do you see him
as no different from the other villains
we met so far it's he ironically the
biggest hypocrite of all killing heroes
and indirectly increasing villainy as he
claims to be seeking a just world there
are still some things left unanswered
like what exactly happens to stains
parents I definitely look forward to
learning more as I go on reading the
manga whenever you think of stain his
presence has raised some interesting
questions and contribute to making the
world of my hero academia more complex
and interesting sometimes you do have to
wonder trim these heroes be saving
people instead of endorsing commercial
products anyways that's it for today's
video guys thanks so much for watching
if you enjoyed this video Detroit smash
that like button and don't forget to
subscribe for more my hero academia
videos until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you